the golden globes will go on despite
this pandemic and let me tell you
something
i snuck through the ballroom and i saw
the new virtual stage it is
incredible and all i can tell you about
this year's show is expect
the unexpected
for the first time these besties will be
bi-coastal sunday night
you know me i'm hollywood and i'm a
human
bagel so it just makes sense tina will
host from new york city's rainbow room
where the stage is set
and sanitizer is on standby amy will
take the stage here
inside the beverly hilton ballroom
why so east and west coast presenters
including last year's winners
aquafina renee zellweger and joaquin
phoenix can appear in person
without traveling during the pandemic as
for who determines the winners
just 87 international journalists make
up the voting members of the hollywood
foreign press association
notably the hfpa does not include
any black members i want to see that
dance they call
the black bottom and this year the
organization took major heat for
excluding critically acclaimed black
maid and lead films like
mahrani's black bottom and the five
bloods from the best picture nominations
i'm fight good a hfpa rep tells et the
organization is working on an action
plan
to bring in new black members as soon as
possible but when the winners are
announced
you won't have a bunch of drunken celebs
sitting down in front of you
i guess not no stars will accept their
awards via zoom like we saw during the
emmys
shit's creek but don't expect a hazmat
suit delivery
there will be no red carpet this year
but perry mason's best tv drama actor
nominee
matthew reese and his longtime love
carrie russell have a plan
we've gone through all the options of
dressing the kids up like paparazzi and
coming to the door
elbowing each other and fighting going
this way this way knowing that if i
don't win the kids i'll be like
loser and when it comes to fashion
banks amanda seyfried who announced the
birth of her second child in september
is going big head to toe no i'm
desperate for a russian moment
i'll give it to you i promise two-time
nominee leslie odom jr told us his
fashion goal
to make a splash with wife nicolette we
want to make your couple's moments
that's just
you